[Music]
one of the things that we're about with
this space is not just speaking from the
lectern but having a dialogue
stimulating conversations and and so
that's really the idea behind tonight's
event as you know there are folks here
wearing name tags all of whom have some
some personal work that they do that's
related to refugees or migrants and one
way or the other and hopefully you've
had a chance to introduce yourself and
chat with some of them tonight we're
going to continue that exact same sort
of conversation after this talk so just
think of this is not the main event but
just one aspect of an event that as you
hear things you want to find out more
about we're not going to be able to
cover everything in every aspect of this
area tonight so you're gonna make the
program and if there's somebody who has
an interesting is working in an aspect
of this you're interested then find them
afterwards keep that conversation going
and talk amongst yourselves as well the
last thing I'll mention is just a quick
shout out to Edward Burtynsky who is a
an artist and filmmaker who's spoken for
us before he is sponsoring our live
streaming capabilities were able to do
that thanks to his support in 2016 and
you can find at at Anthropocene on
twitter is his Anthropocene film which
is coming out next year so this this
image is the the image of the year for
the world World Press Photo image of the
year and it is taken by a Australian
photographer named Warren Richardson on
the border between [ __ ] ghosts in
Serbia and rosca in Hungary part of a
series called the refugee crisis Hungary
it's a man who's handing his baby
through barbed wire lit only by
moonlight and it highlights the fact
that clearly this topic we're going to
talk about tonight is as captured us it
is raw and it is happening in real time
and here at the long now foundation with
with all of our series we really pride
ourselves on taking a long-term view and
short term thinking is needed to and
short term action is needed as well but
one of the things tonight as we're
feeling a lot of emotions and and and a
lot of involvement in in refugee issues
and migrant issues is that we keep a
long term perspective and so that's one
aspect we're going to be talking tonight
is how we look at at this situation over
time and that we need to plan for it as
we continue forward so that we can deal
with it better tomorrow because these
are these are issues that are not going
away what we see here is a graph showing
the refugees that are in protracted
displacement so more than five years so
when someone crosses the border a large
percentage when people across the world
a large percentage of them are not
returning they are staying in this other
state which we're going to talk about a
lot more for for a long amount of time
so that's the the orange that you see
that persists so today's refugee
situation has a lot of yesterday's
refugees situation for decades and we
see refugee camps that are sticking
around for four decades and we'll talk
about some of those when we look back in
time this is a - ancient Athens
classical Athens there was a huge value
in Athenian culture to take care of
those in need who came to take care of
refugees this is not a new problem a new
situation and at the same time that it
was exalted as a value and something
they took pride in it was also something
still divided society so we find plays
sophocles that talk about accepting
people from that are coming in as
refugees and that it causes debates and
it causes strife the idea of it as well
as the fact of it and we're seeing that
in our society today so in in some ways
just to say so many of these things are
not new here's a piece of a fundamental
idea from long now's history that Danny
Hillis our our founder said a lot of
times when we look at a situation we
look at a problem and try and solve that
in two years it seems impossible but if
we reframe that around decades around
centuries we say oh there's a way we
could approach this we could start doing
things in building towards it so that's
just one of the frames we want to think
about tonight that kind of idea that
we're not just limited to the tools that
can have an impact right now that we
start conversations that can lead to
larger larger goals and and larger
achievements over time this is a graph
that points out something really
important or a a map that points out
something really important so this is
about internal displacement so someone
who's displaced within a country is not
a refugee by the technical political
definition we'll talk more about that so
one of the things to understand is that
when people draw a circle around
refugees and are thinking about solving
that problem it's not really the whole
the right problem it's not the whole
problem there's displacement that's
going on and if you're only looking at
the set of people that are that
technical classification of refugees
we're leaving a lot of people out who
are in just as challenging situations at
long now we one of the tenants in
addition to long the long now is the big
here and the idea is to live in a longer
now and also bigger here and the world
is are here and it's a challenge like
migration and refugees reminds us that
we're one big
and these are some some numbers that
point to the fact that that the shared a
more shared approach can help us balance
the challenges and and and and make some
of those most stressed zones
you know diminish in in those those
challenges so I just wanted to put up a
few of these things to get us started
now I'm gonna take a back seat and bring
on some folks who are working with this
situation every day and the global
challenges of migrant and Refugee
populations
please welcome Hugh if you want to come
up and you want to walk us through a
little bit first of all about your
organization and your relations first I
want to thank Michael for organizing
this he's put a lot of work into this we
actually started having this
conversation about a year ago so we were
both kind of hoping that it would
partially go away but that hasn't
happened in a year is actually seems to
have gotten worse
and we hear more and more about it every
day in the news with seizures and the
narrative doesn't really seem to be
changing so it's it's timely in the
sense that that we're all coming
together just a quick show of hands who
has experienced direct experience with
refugees or internally displaced people
so a fair number of people okay so each
one of you brings a unique and special
perspective to the issue so you know
part of this is a discussion and after
the sort of the formal presentation is
over we invite you all to get together
and and see if we can maybe share some
ideas rapid prototype some solutions and
and and keep the conversation going so I
am a founder and executive director of
reboot camp and what we do is we train
Syrian refugees to code
we've got some great partners and we've
sort of identified our strategies to
sort of identify gaps in the market and
then sort of train the refugees to sort
of fill those gaps so it's a it's a way
that they can kind of get some of their
self-respect back kind of continue on
with their life five years going into
the Syrian conflict now and that's sort
of where my wheelhouse is the you know
that the opportunities are are starting
to thin out hope is starting to diminish
you know for one or two years it was
like people were kind of expecting that
the situation would stabilize they could
return but that hasn't been the case so
going on five years now in in many of
the refugee areas in the camps in Jordan
in the informal camps in Lebanon Turkey
you have no tertiary education so and
with computer can speak to this a little
bit only half the kids the can begin
school are in school so education is a
real is a real concern and it's sort of
the area that we've we've been focusing
on the numbers almost 60 million now ID
fees those are internally displaced
people as Mike was talking about early
on these are people that haven't left
the borders but they've been forced out
of their cities or they and and and the
reasons are as we'll see are varied but
and they actually IDPs account for
actually most of the displaced people
total number of refugees pushing 20
million now and these are a lot a big
portion of this is because of Syria four
and a half million the main reasons are
war of course conflict and climate in
many cases farmers have been you know
working a piece of land for years
generations and generations but because
of droughts and stuff like that they've
had to relocate this is
one of the reasons that's that's sort of
posited why the Syrian conflict started
we had a lot of farmers that were moving
into the cities just causing stress and
so during the Arab Spring there was a
sort of a well overreaction to to the
protests a lot of which were being led
by these farmers and we're not happy
number of people fleeing each day this
is about this is the population of Menlo
Park this is the number of people that
are move on the move every day most of
them are are are young a lot of women
and children also a lot of older people
so average day in a refugee camp or
average average status as a refugee now
is pushing nineteen years that's a what
it's been that stabili or is that
increasing it's increased it was in 2012
it was 17 years so in four years we've
added another two years there's a lot of
reasons why people don't return to their
country of origin
sometimes they can't go back sometimes
there's nothing to go back to sometimes
maybe a case of your neighbor you know
murdered your your your cousin so
there's just like very very bad blood
you know and there's no reason to go
back so this is the right now we're
almost at 20 million and by 2020 they're
projecting 50 million refugees and of
course the Syrians the Syrian problem is
is is one of the reasons why I'm here
today just a little background I started
I've been working with the UN now for
about three years and we started doing
athletic programs in what was like the
third largest refugee camp at the time
was a three refugee camp in North Jordan
and from that we've got involved in the
in the education
but 4.8 saurian 4.8 million Syrian
refugees about 800,000 in Jordan a man
and a half in Lebanon two and a half
million in Turkey and the balance or
sort of spread out through Iraq and and
now Europe this is just this is sort of
where I've been operating in Zachary and
this just goes to show sort of the rapid
development and how it sort of grew
organically it's actually the largest
concentration of Syrians outside of
Syria remains at about eighty thousand
eighty two thousand they just had their
five thousandth birth in the camp five
the five thousand baby was born I think
yesterday and they have like three to
four births a day and that's generally
the average size eighty-five thousand
most are younger than then 18 only half
er I've half the kids are in school why
is that in many cases the parents keep
them out of school to work and you say
well what kind of work gets done in a
refugee camp well
Zachary's like up has this whole sort of
black market economy going on there's
3,000 businesses in Zachary right now so
kids do everything from a concrete to
you know deliver pizza and the most of
the refugees actually live outside the
camps and this is because there's more
there's more opportunities in the cities
even though the refugees are not allowed
to work Syrian refugees are not allowed
to work in and Jordan Lebanon Turkey
they do probably 80% of them work
the government doesn't enforce it
because they're doing jobs that nobody
else wants to do
much like the migrant labor here so
there's been a lot of different
solutions
this is one undp I'm sorry UN HCR
innovation is promoting how to sort of
stay in touch with each other using
social media in a lot of different
responses from a lot of different folks
you know there's Skype in the classroom
in in Kenya or another innovation UNHCR
innovation project we're sort of pop-up
schools medical folks have gotten
involved in terms of containers the tech
industry is it's taken a sort of a big a
big and they've got a big initiative to
develop different types of tech
solutions from 3d printing of prosthetic
limbs to haptic sensors for people that
have lost their their vision to early
warning barrel bomb applications that
they can have when they're on their
smartphones so lots going on there this
is this is organization rbk and what
we're doing is we're sort of we're
identifying gaps in the market and a
huge one is of course is the tech
industry entry level developers and
engineers are in great demand in the
region and what we're doing with the
help of a code boot camp here in San
Francisco hack reactor is we are there
on one of our main partners is we're
teaching refugee refugees to code and
then we've we have hiring partnerships
in the in the region where where these
companies have promised to hire our
graduates and and on that let's say on
that for a second so one of the things
you're doing is it's not exclusively for
the refugees right also sort of so in
any any good humanitarian practice is
you train an equal number of refugees
and host Nationals so in this particular
case we are training half Syrian
refugees and then half Jordanian
nationals but we're targeting the
at-risk populations there's areas in
Jordan like kazarka it's a Salafist
strong
and they supply more fighters to Isis
than any other city in the world by just
a major major amount so we're
identifying at-risk kids in these areas
also in the border areas where
unemployment it's like 80 percent and
they have right now they've got they've
got a choice between an ak-47 and an
ak-47 depending on which side is
offering them more money because they're
being recruited by Isis they're being
recruited by al-shabaab by you know the
other extremist organizations so we're
giving them a third choice a career for
the young women the the coping
strategies were just as bad it's
basically teen marriage either forced or
volunteer so you have these 13 14 year
old girls that are sort of being kicked
out of the house if they don't want to
go on their own they're you know they're
their parents are forcing them out or
marrying them off in some cases to you
know foreigners so we're offering these
young women also a sort of a another
another choice when we Natasha do you
want to come up why don't we jump back
for a second - to this idea about the
the populations that are outside and I
think that's maybe a great place for you
to just say come on so as you know we
have a lot of of experts in our myths
and if and several of them are many of
them are in the audience so as we call
on you for a question and you're one of
those folks we'd look or even if we
don't know about your expertise yet we'd
love you to stand up and just briefly
sort of say who you are and and your
background what you how your relation to
this is and Natasha is going to give us
a great example of that to start us off
I'm on sabbatical this year and I am at
Stanford
at the Center for the Advanced Study of
the behavioral sciences I always get
that wrong but not tonight so I don't
work on refugees specifically I work on
migration writ large and my my
contribution here tonight is maybe to
frame this question around what we
understand the refugee crisis to be and
how we define or distinguish rather
refugees from migrants so the concept of
a refugee is actually a legal concept
that emerged in the immediate post-war
years the convention was ratified in
1951 and it is a distinction that grew
out of the failure of European countries
primarily to deal with the world war two
refugees the massive movement of people
who had been displaced by this
cataclysmic event this is the
distinction that we still use and we
haven't deployed it or thought through
it as deliberately as we've been
thinking about it over the past five
years because the the major refugee
crises were the major forced
displacement of people have been in
areas that have received far less
coverage in the US and in Europe so
primarily sub-saharan Africa and with
internal displacement in sub-saharan
Africa and Latin America Colombia
primarily Colombia has a huge internally
displaced persons problem in fact it was
interesting in your map that the the
causes for displacement were all natural
disasters but in fact in Colombia that
the major cause of displacement is
actually pilots and civil war so my
understanding is that it might be
helpful to present a little bit of the
long now yes well no it's always welcome
right so this notion is a is a notion
that emerged right after the world after
world war two and for the u.s. the North
Atlantic region and Europe migration has
been for the most part the steady
regulated
flow of people it's been there have been
labor movement Accords right so Europe
imported guest workers from North Africa
from Turkey the u.s. signed the bracero
program with Mexico and regulated flows
that had informal undocumented
components but no big spikes the big
spike is what has drawn our attention
the big spike to Europe has drawn our
attention to the refugee crisis today
Lebanon and Turkey and Jordan have
experienced these flows and big numbers
really since the beginning of the civil
war the u.s. in particular has in its
history and I know there's an American
historian and audience here so I may
stand corrected but in its history the
US has experienced these big spikes and
has not had the same kind of anxiety
around these big spikes in the past so
one example that for me is very poignant
is the Irish potato famine
so Ireland between 1930 1847 and which
was the year the first year of the
famine and 1851 lost 1.5 million people
and it was a population in the census
but the last census before the famine
listed the population of Ireland and 8
million so that that's an equivalent
number to the kind of displacement
proportionally that you see from Syria
today and most of the so a huge number
of Irish ended up on in New York in
Boston in Philadelphia and in Montreal
Toronto they were they traveled across
the Atlantic in slave ships that had
been repurposed for the movement of
Irish immigrants and Manhattan which in
1847 had a population of 300,000
received 200,000 I
people in two years and it's population
grew by 1/4 so did so to the population
of Boston Philadelphia there's one more
city that I'm forgetting Baltimore no
Chicago didn't get a lot of Irish they
did they got a lot of Germans who moved
Midwest to the Midwest but these
populations were not tagged as refugees
they were just seen as migrants on the
cities that received them absorb them we
didn't we didn't tagged them differently
that the the tagging of refugees as
distinct from migrants is a new
phenomenon as is the sense that the
cities in Europe and North America
cannot absorb them we have in the past
and it wasn't as traumatic as one might
think
right so it's shaped our understanding
so things like infrastructure and
poverty but basically basically we have
in the past had this capacity and it's
this new tagging that has transformed
our vision of what we can absorb and
what we can't absorb and I just want to
say two words about this tagging and
then maybe I'll turn the microphone over
there is a representation of refugees as
it's almost like a sanctification right
they are fleeing persecution and and
it's a particular kind of understanding
of persecution its persecution that is
generated by a state body or its
equivalent it's not random violence in
your neighborhood which is why we have
such a difficult time understanding
refugee flows or people fleeing violence
in Central America it's much more fraud
it's much messier we have street gangs
here what you know so why are those
people refugees so there's a kind of
understanding that this violence must be
organized by some sort of official or
quasi official body and there's almost a
sanctification of refugees they are
innocent victims we we like to think of
them as
the people who got caught in the
crossfire and they are caught in the
crossfire of a particular kind of
violence they're not fleeing economic
necessity they are not fleeing violence
that grows out of different kind of
tensions in their community or different
forms of global commerce like the drug
trade they are fleeing a particular kind
of violence and so since they are
fleeing this kind of violence they we
need to provide many many services for
them and those services are costly and
we can't absorb them and so on and so
forth and and you're talking about the
institutional system only recognizes
those so when you say yes we have
feelings about other other types of
migrants but but as far as the ones who
can get the can get asylum can get can
get that recognition and and that
assistance but that is silent is that
it's a great question because that
Asylum is actually an interpretive and
very fraught process that depends on the
people adjudicating those cases how do
they is this really a legitimate form of
violence or is it not so is this a
legitimate claim or is it not
but anyone who is fleeing or migrating
because of extreme poverty or extreme
violence that isn't represented in these
politically palatable ways or maybe as
it has happened in the past they are
coming from a country that is our ally
and it is our ally that is oppressing
people so we're not gonna record that
snot goodbye let's just you know
obedience training yeah something you
know they're just having an argument
it's not yes oh and the comments there
that this is a rich and important topic
I'm really glad that were here well this
is great sue so why don't you have a
seat up here Beverly would you mind
coming up and and I'm gonna have you
come up and I'm gonna ask a question to
see so I'm really interested in
something you just said there's a notion
I keep thinking about as I learn more
about it it's like well so they're
filling out paperwork in these were is
that this is somehow if I know there are
people here who've worked in and
probably once you come up and have a
seat and will let me see
for those of you who have worked in
camps have been a part of camps have you
are there there folks here who have been
a part of that process of people
applying for asylum and and what that
dialogues like what that process is like
does anyone
Sergio are you here Sergio do we have
the other other microphone here we go
Sergio we got the the my career just
just quickly introduce yourself and and
make sure the microphone is on everybody
Sergio Medina I'm the founder of rise
its refugee and immigrant services so
the question is so as we're hearing
about people that are applying for
asylum they're in they're in a refugee
camp they would like to get asylum
what's that process like are they
literally filling out forms what's what
is their bureaucracy they're going
through how is that interpreted because
one of the things we're seeing is
there's two ways yeah there's two ways
to do it one is one by one and if you do
it for 50 million people it's gonna take
you decades to do it or what you can do
it on mass everyone in here is a refugee
you and I are UN staff we're all UN
staff you guys all come in we can say
we're gonna interview each and every one
of you or we're just gonna say are you
all from San Francisco Bay Area do you
all get discriminated against because
they everyone thinks you're wealthy okay
so we're gonna we're gonna say everyone
here meets that definition and you guys
are all de facto refugees but and so
what we'll do is we'll issue a de facto
number right to this group of San
Francisco Bay Area discriminated against
because of the wealthy group and then
you guys will come in and you say hey
you guys can go to the camp you guys can
go to Oakland and try to find a job so
it sort of happens like that there's no
single point of entry into a country to
get status and it's it's not about
massive massive flows of people there's
all sorts of conventions whether it's
like whether it's a european convention
or an african states convention a
Refugee Convention and latin american
colombian states convention just to
complicate
mmm-hmm Thanks all right well thank you
Sergio Ramos was for Sergio and Beverly
where I thought would be a good point to
connect with you on a couple things your
expertise no let you introduce yourself
but your expertise in Europe and in
Germany in particular obviously Germans
Germany's reaction to this has been well
covered and and has controversy around
it but I know that you were also in
Turkey so I'd love to have you you say
something about your experiences last
year in Turkey but maybe yeah yeah yeah
and make sure to hold the microphone
Greg my name is Beverly Crawford and I
teach at UC Berkeley I actually just
retired congratulations but I'm still
teaching to keep my brain going I would
I spent last summer in Turkey I was
there to do to do research on refugees
and to do demographic research because
very little is known about you know how
many people are how old and with women
and men and children I mean the UNHCR
has has these broad numbers that you
clean up here but but there's very
little done on who are so that's what we
were we were doing and as we went out to
interview people we realized how much
they were suffering and we always
brought some diapers to the mothers and
baby clothes and things that they needed
and throughout the winter we brought
well my colleagues brought brought coal
and wood for them so that so that we
became kind of a research aid
organization I would say we're not we
weren't incorporated what interested me
most and what what upsets me a lot is
that is that as Natasha was talking
about we have this UN Convention on
refugees which only covers a particular
group and not those fleeing certain
kinds of violence
climate climate
there are so many climate refugees
fleeing disasters but countries who sign
the Refugee Convention are obligated to
accept a refugee on their soil and the
rep the person will say I'm a refugee
and they are and they are obligated to
allow that person to apply for asylum
however it's a catch-22 because they do
everything they can to keep the refugees
out so you can't you are legal if you're
in and you're actually legal if you're
out but since you're kept out you have
to go to Europe let's say you're up or
even the United States we know that in
an irregular way and so many people are
risking their lives to get the get the
the rights the human rights that they
that they are entitled to and so 4,000
people died on the Mediterranean Sea
last year and the European Union has I I
asked them I know refugees fly me I mean
they could fly they they pay smugglers 1
to $2,000 dollars a head like you could
fly from assemble to Berlin for 300
dollars they don't fly because you have
to have documents to fly you have to
have a visa to fly if you're a refugee
you're you're sometimes there without
documents and certainly you don't have a
visa because refugees don't get visas so
the trick is to get in and then you're
legal and so people have to people have
to take these very dangerous dangerous
journeys first they escape danger and in
life-threatening circumstances in the
countries they left then they had to
maybe leave the camps and the camps are
very much underfunded I don't
50 cents a day for for food in the camps
for each refugee they so they they the
camps and staying there 19 years is not
really you know the prospects of the
future are not good and so refugees want
to go to places where they can work
places where they can have a livelihood
where they can live where they can
educate their children and so they they
have to risk their lives yet again on
this incredibly dangerous journey
because because the European Union will
not let you fly and enter Europe and the
United States isn't the same without a
proper visa even though you're legally
entitled to this and so now Europe is
sending now the the NATO the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization is sending
warships into the Mediterranean Sea and
they and the pretense is we are going to
pick up human traffickers and we are not
going to send refugees back because
they're not really allowed by
international law to do that but there
are no smugglers on the boats that bring
refugees from Turkey to Greece yeah so
there's a film I don't think I ended up
showing it because the technology didn't
line up but I'll send it a link to this
afterwards things called journeyman TB
journeyman TV is in a series of videos
of various aspects of the refugees and
migration situation so they have a piece
with a French company I believe was them
and they show one of these so maybe
maybe you can help me sort of talk to
you have you seen well this might this
might be maybe maybe it's but it's
probably similar so soon so what was
interesting and alarming to find out was
these these this this business that
these smugglers are running is they
bring a both it's in pretty crappy shape
usually they've arranged for I'm not
sure
how much people are paying to make the
transit but as you said it's much more
than than a plane ticket and we'll we'll
talk about this organization which you
brought up in a second and then they
load everyone on the boat and the
smugglers dive off and swim to shore and
they go count their money and they hand
the controls to whoever happens to be
closest to them and one of the refugees
then tries to take this boat to its
destination and then when they get there
very often the EU rule is that the first
country you're in right is the first
country you're in you have to ask for
amnesty there but most of them don't
want to be in the first country that
they're in so they're off on the next
leg of this Planes Trains and you know
death defying Odyssey to try and get to
a more desirable country for them so
it's it's it's insane suit so so let's
talk about refugee air because you
you've brought up this organization I
think to me right who are trying to do
something about that this is great a
great group which are some former
refugees who live in Sweden actually
from Iran and they they were as shocked
as I am about this terrible catch-22
that refugees are in so they said why
don't we charter a plane go down vet the
refugees and make sure that they are
refugees you know and that that they
will be granted asylum or you know
pretty close to it that they will be and
we'll just fly them over in a charter
plane and so they've already started
they said we're going to do this before
the first snow falls in Sweden I'm not
sure they managed that yet but they but
they definitely have started and I
didn't say that airlines have to pay a
fine if they if they let a refugee on
even though that person's a refugee they
have to pay a fine to the European Union
if they take a refugee that's
undocumented on't have to pay a fine
they're in a charter plane so so
hopefully this will get off the ground
so to speak and and to drop in the
bucket yeah and you had also brought up
the science for Refugees program do you
wanted to say where this is actually a
program in the in the European Union the
European Union has that will take people
who are scientists who've been trained
and scientists in their home country and
and after after they have already been
granted refugee status but actually to
give them into the workforce as
scientists and so they have a whole
process for this to happen and so this
is York wants I highly trained people
they know I only trained people losing
population like mad Germany's loses two
hundred thousand people a year from the
workforce just just because they're not
having babies and and one touch point
with long now that we have with this
particular issue is if any of you seen
our talk by George Dyson he talks about
the amazing scientists the incredible
brains who came from Eastern Europe in
the run-up to World War two who were
fleeing were refugees and came to
Princeton and and for a small amount of
money we were able to not only get the
benefits of their great minds but saved
our lives in a very real sense and
that's an incredible brain trust that
we've had so clearly clear there all
kinds of people that are that are caught
up in this kind of forced migration so
we should talk maybe a little bit more
about the camps and life in the camps I
think you were saying that well but
let's actually why don't we let's get
some questions from from the audience
right here in the the corner
great and and we'll actually use that
microphone and pass around the people
that are asking questions financially
but the the question was what is
Germany's process that allows them to
take a greater amount of refugees what's
what's that it's not a process it's a
decision on the part of Angela Merkel
the Chancellor who said we will first
said we will take 800,000 refugees this
year in 2015 it was raised to a million
now but every country has its own has
its own and it can make its own
decisions and so Germany has decided to
do that then tried to pressure other
European countries to take they're a few
thousand and has caused a lot of
dissension and is is there is there a
dialog within the EU around around
around making that not as optional but
more very much so it's the EU has made
it mandatory but not in a good way
because they didn't have a consensus
they just took a majority vote and the
most powerful the biggest countries got
together and said we get together we can
have a coalition and we can push this
through so we can have a mandate for
every state in the European Union to
take refugees and the East European
countries did not want to do that at all
they they said no Slovakia said we're
only taking Christians we're not taking
Muslims and that's you know and they
went on and on in that way and that's
setting a really wonderful precedent
Germany is but I have you know for the
last 20 years the United States has been
the leader in refugee research permanent
refugee resettlement in the world so
much so that the US has resettled more
refugees in our communities then the
rest of the world combined and that has
been the case for the last 25 30 years
the Sudanese the Vietnamese right here
in San Francisco and Oakland all over
the United States the US has led the
charge and there was a time where the US
and all our glory were Shamy in other
countries too
the same at the level that we were doing
and if there's one issue that is that
gets bipartisan support you were talking
about the sanctity of refugees and its
refugee issues Republicans and Democrats
support refugee resettlement in ways
that they will never support knock on
wood services for migrants who are
different than refugees but I think it's
worth saying that the United States has
always been the leader in refugee
resettlement in other countries like
Germany you're following suit
finally and if they're going to do
quotas in Australia it's been great
UK Canada New Zealand Sweden makes
medical cases but for the European Union
to absorb the current wave it's entirely
possible that was likely not only is it
possible their neighbors and it should
be happening at much higher level so
uncle Merkel wherever you are thank you
and the Germans are so good you know
organizing these things
it's administratively not a problem 350
million people in Europe and 1 million
refugees it's the if Europe needs these
people they need refugees they need
people to work this
Europe's losing population yeah no I was
just gonna point out that the same year
that they've been pointing out that
Europe is losing population and that
there's empty towns in Italy and in
Spain
it's the same year they're saying that
they don't want all these refugees and
so in the same countries which is very
ironic and and and I like I want to send
out that I think I'm conflating to film
because there's another piece that shows
an Italian crew cuz there was a time
when the Italians were particularly in
charge of
of taking care of revenues this is I
think 2013 maybe 2013 when it was but
didn't was handed over to an EU force
who was much less sympathetic to getting
close to the other side in short there's
obviously very differing cultural
attitudes towards towards towards
accepting people as their as they're
coming through what are the questions do
we have
what's over here thank you I have two
questions the first one is let me
preface this by saying I'm in favor of
the free movement of people for whatever
reason they want and most of the
Europeans I know are welcoming the the
refugees that are that are coming there
the Europeans that I know that are not
say that there's a direct relation with
equality and that Northern Europe has
has very low Gini coefficients and that
that by virtue of having people in those
countries it gives them a responsibility
that the United States does not feel for
its population us agriculture is
dependent on undocumented workers in a
way that that that's not the case in
Europe and in other countries like
Colombia with a lot of IDPs with with
with Lebanon the government does not in
fact do very much for them it doesn't
feel that it has a responsibility or
doesn't have a capacity to do that so
what is my answer to Europeans that
would say that the second question I I
have is a general topic that I'm curious
about that from the sort of long-term
point of view is that right
right now the Kremlin is in a positioned
itself in a very adversarial way with
the west and
in my opinion what what the Kremlin is
doing right now by the bombing campaign
in in support of the government of Syria
is essentially creating a refugee tab
that is that is splitting Europe and he
sees that and it is Putin sees that it's
in its interests do you see that as a
future way the creation of refugees as a
tool of warfare in the way this cyber
war or other forms of of insurgency may
maybe could that happen in other other
other places too easy questions actually
that you want - oh yeah I can respond
just very quickly to the last part of
your last question because it's the only
part I remember no I do remember the
other parts scorched earth policy has
been around for a long time and
politicians and dictators and leaders
have used it very purposefully to create
geopolitical conflict to their benefit
in to their gain so the fact that this
is happening if he--if Luton and is
whatever you call them are supporting
the creation of war refugees that's not
a new political tactic it's like call
your call your [ __ ] we know what
you're doing
it's creating the more divisive this and
so that's it's a really common
unfortunately a very common tactic in
civil war and an armed conflict and who
loses in most of that it's the civilians
it's not the troops it's I mean they
might you know I don't want to minimize
that but for the majority it's the
civilians that lose out and those
underhanded tactics
so I'll take your first question I don't
know if I have the right answer to your
European prints but I have possibly one
answer so in Jordan and Lebanon where
Palestinians have been a large portion
of the population and have been
long-term refugees now 60 years plus
their what you have is a kind of tiered
labor market where Palestinians are
allowed to do some jobs but not all and
they're in a much more vulnerable legal
position so you have this kind of
structured or engineered inequality
right so what that means is that for
someone in Sweden or someone in a
Scandinavian country with it with a
notion of citizenship that's organized
around equality right and the state
works very hard to redistribute
resources among its populace if it if it
accepts a refugee which it's bound to do
and then denies that refugee full access
to the privileges of being in that
polity you create an inequality that
hurts everybody right and so the u.s. as
well I mean you can your European
friends might say it's easier for the
u.s. to absorb people and and by the way
I'm not sure that we absorb more people
per capita right I think we do okay
we've done not so great lately and we
have a great record on deportation
deportations were outstanding right but
the fact that we don't provide the same
services is because we tolerate a level
of structural inequality in our country
that is disturbing to most outside
observers in Europe and to many many of
us in this country so I think it's about
the kind of society you want to live in
and let's Peter if we have somebody else
with a nametag if you you ready to come
I did I started off thinking well we can
only have three people on the stage and
I'm like this is about refugees let's
get crowded on our
so Peter you want to come up come up
right here grab the mic and and you've
done work in in Africa oh no no come
over here come over here all so so we've
been talking a lot about Europe but I
know you've worked in the field and in
various ways in Africa so tell us are
these things tend to follow the same or
are there different dynamics we haven't
talked about yet and for everyone if
you've got one of these handheld mics
make sure to hold it very close you
can't hold it too close and sorry why
don't you first introduce yourself and
what you do today what your what your
role is sure so my name is Peter trans
Berg and I work for an acronym inee
is the acronym it stands for the
interagency network for education and
emergencies our whole focus is on
providing education in crisis contexts
so refugee situations are a piece of
that internally displaced settings are
also a piece of that how do you get kids
back to school after a disaster how do
you provide safe passage and safe places
for them to go during a conflict and so
on and so forth that's our whole mission
is to make sure that the right to
education which is standard for everyone
you hopefully all got to enjoy that
right throughout your life that that
right is not diminished or neglected or
ignored in any situation especially in
conflict situations or in crisis
situations so that's our focus
we partner with UNHCR with UNICEF the
big UN agencies who do humanitarian work
but also have an education component and
also the big NGOs Save the Children and
International Rescue Committee and Mercy
Corps and others who also do
humanitarian response but also some sort
of education so there are big partners
we have a couple hundred of hundred
partners that work within the network
but about 12,000 individual members who
work around the world in a whole variety
of contexts every context you can
imagine where crisis is happening in
education is impacted
and that could be yeah in in Latin
America work gang violence is a problem
it can be in sub-saharan Africa where
militias are preventing children from
getting to school or where cyclone is
hit and certainly it has to do with with
refugee situations and Syria being the
big situation for the last few years
that our partners have focused on my
personal experience is largely been in
Africa and mainly with internally
displaced people not so much with
refugees I've never worked in a camp
have only visited and have mainly worked
with internally displaced IDPs the
problems are similar and I don't want to
repeat what they're saying here and I
like I said I'm learning a lot about the
situation even though this is certainly
on our radar a lot on our radar but the
fact is they're somewhere just under
three million Syrian children who are
out of school children and youth 2.8 is
the sort of best estimate of of children
and youth who are out of school they're
not in school they're not actively
engaged or enrolled in school right now
and that's hugely worrying some of them
that's been a few months some of them
that's been for almost five years now
and that has an impact on them right now
especially sitting out in school they're
not necessarily in a safe place they're
looking for things to do their parents
are sending them to go do certain things
in many cases and it's gonna have an
impact next year and in five years and
25 years that gap of so many children
not being not pursuing an education
right now will have ripple effects for
it's another Lost Generation kind of
scenario absolutely so the focus that we
try to put on it is that there's action
that needs to be taken now immediately
in the case of any kind of crisis we're
always there with the with the food the
water the shelter and we're always
saying okay you guys do your thing on
the first three days fourth day we're
coming in education needs to be part of
this emergency response from the
beginning not the fourth week not the
fourth month not next year needs to
happen starting now this the first week
of a response once people have
with water and shelter but that
education provides a normalcy to
children and youth that is hugely
impactful on them and on their entire
families allows parents to get back
rebuilding their lives or whatever that
might be it ensures that they have some
safe place to go it's however not easy
it's not as easy as saying ok send your
kid to the school because it's a safe
place and we know that we know where
that is and and every everything is
going to be just fine in a case like
refugee situation in Syria where
children are in Turkey where they don't
speak the language or they're in Jordan
or in Lebanon or
all the way in Europe it's not easy to
just take them into your classroom which
might are to be over full teachers don't
know how to deal with them they don't
have to cope with them so a lot of what
we're doing is working with ministries
of Education and with the organizations
who are providing education programming
to learn how to do that for your
specific context what do you need do you
need more training for the teachers do
you need more space do you need to build
new classrooms do you need to do double
shifts what are the what are the
strategies that need you need to put in
place in your community and as you can
imagine it's a it's it's a big job and
varies depending on the context
depending on the country so so we're
getting a little bit close on our time I
want to is there anyone out there who's
got a question that you haven't heard
addressed at all is there there's a
topic we haven't even touched on because
there's so much there's so much to cover
here you have something with some here
you go spring a person go ahead and
stand up and yes maybe it's not entirely
a question as much of a comment but I'm
hearing a lot of different problems I'm
hearing things about them being
connected and I'm wondering if someone's
done a sort of systematic typology of
all challenges that affect refugee and
migration worked according to domain
scale and time so that somebody can
reason
and you know people who are one
contributing health can figure out where
to position themselves but secondly also
to understand what are all of the missed
opportunities we have for changing these
foundational conditions and to which
these problems are so long and and and
I'll tag on to that is their best
practices sharing is there I mean UNHCR
is touching a lot of these things is or
others are way for learnings to bubble
up and be shared and different scenarios
does anyone have have an answer to that
or the best answer that you've got a mic
you know I can say a couple things on
that right no no one has the full
mapping yet anyway I think it's such
it's such a fluid situation that it's
really it is difficult to map a migrant
population and what are all their needs
and people are moving they're on they're
on the move you mentioned earlier that
that some organizations have in UNHCR of
course because their refugee agency is
leading on a lot of this but some
organizations have have have tried
innovative approaches we do know that
Syrian refugees generally about 80% have
smartphones so we know that that people
have done some some mapping of that so
we understand that they have at least a
smartphone they may not have backups for
it or a computer at home or anything
else but they have a smartphone so they
have access to apps and so there has
been a lot of efforts to create
interesting especially on the education
side interesting and useful and good
learning apps for children who are on
the move the Norwegians have been behind
that putting some funding into that with
USAID and others to try and develop
actual base the basic things like
literacy apps for children who are just
out of school so there's some efforts
it's the little piecemeal focused on a
particular segment of a population in a
particular area in a particular language
but there are some efforts like that
yeah maybe I'll leave it at that
you teach each country has its sort of
own response regional response like in
the case of Jordan they get everybody
they're the ministers of you know all
the sort of different agencies they
bring in UNHCR they bring in UNICEF UNDP
everybody and and at some point they are
actually sitting in one room trying to
map out US or a long term response and
there they're famous for generating very
very thick documents on on the solution
but unfortunately that's that doesn't
really go beyond the borders because the
the issues are so border driven
Lebanon has its own sort of issues that
that are different than Jordan and and
Kenya might have its own sort of issues
that are different than Somalia so it's
it's largely sort of localized but there
is there is at some point a discussion
where everybody's in the room yeah oh
you haven't gone you want to reduce
yourself and yeah and miss Monica please
so my name is Sarah I am from Italy so I
like to actually bring in a more
personal perspective to all of this
because it's great to think about the
foundation and there's a bigger problem
but in the end of the day it's a lot of
politics so it's really escape our our
our action but I want to bring the
prospectuses friend I lived in fear in
2009 and many of my friends also
expatriates living in Syria now a friend
Syrian they became refugees so what I
did is I followed the refugees from
Greece to Germany in October I followed
a family with four children and it was
really a very meaningful experience
because it's like a friends going with
friends if someone like I mean during
the second world war there were many
people helping the Jewish people fleeing
and you know so I think many of us in
Europe has volunteers it's very
important if these individual action
where governments and states are failing
so we are trying to bridge the gap it's
either working with them or like doing
anything - and so for just to be very
sure what I understood through going
through a trip from Greece to Germany by
foot just imagine you are very hungry
very tired you're very cold and there is
no solution like until you get to
Germany you don't know what's gonna
happen with you because the police might
might take you and okay so now I'm
Italian so at any point I can show my
passport and say I'm Italian so please
let me go especially in Serbia and
Croatia it was very difficult but for
Refugees they you know it's question of
luck so that's the first thing I wanted
to say so I think really connecting on
this individual level it would be very
important because we are here talking
but when you actually go there and just
walk with them because with an American
passport you can do it nothing's gonna
happen to you can actually help them you
can speak to them and understand who
they are and where they are from so if
anyone wants to take that trip I can
give you some names and let me know and
the other thing is in Italian it is true
that it's difficult for us to accept
refugees mostly because we are not an
immigration country like we immigrated
to the u.s. mostly but we never had
refugees before so it's a new thing but
it's not because we are particularly
racist it's more like out of ignorance
that you don't really know who they are
so I think hopefully it's gonna change
in the future and I hope Europe will
open up but there are very many right
wing the government right now so it's a
big challenge but I agree with all of
you that we can take them and the young
people they are very open-minded and we
will try to yeah so uh and and and
[Applause]
Sergio did you yeah I had one a really
quick response to a gentleman who asked
that question and I want to say what's
your name thank you for asking that
question because that's the type of
question that needs to be asked it's an
ambitious question
it's blushing now but I think he what
you said is exactly right that it is
very country specific and I like Peter
have a lot of experience in East Africa
but there are some overarching dynamics
going on one is human rights right to
emergency aid right to education right
to food why right to water right to
protection legal protection and I can
tell you right now guess where the
innovate there are two innovation
centers one is UNHCR
Innovation Center you mentioned earlier
there's a unit UNICEF Innovation Center
but guess where that that the hubs of
technological innovation for the UN are
based in in the work now
she said San Francisco answer's no guess
where they're based Geneva and the
Netherlands are you guys gonna stand for
that so the fact that you asked that
question says we need to create a little
cell sleeper cell thank you scratch that
call it that I don't think innovation
cell here because there are people who
have worked all over the world who are
here and what do we have we have Silicon
Valley we have some really bright bright
minded wonderful people so my
organization just do a little plug we're
trying to do that mapping globally and
we're trying to come up with solutions
but we're a little bitty fish in a very
big pond and we need partners like UN
UNHCR IRC Save the Children and why you
UC Berkeley Stanford you name it and
your organization as well to support so
there are you know maybe this will be
the start up but like next meet up to
think about those really big questions
and how we solve them because we got the
brainpower look at you guys yeah thank
you everyone for showing up like said
please don't go away please keep this
conversation going ask the question you
didn't get a chance to ask here I think
we've just stirred up a bunch of
thoughts and I'm sorry I'm forgetting
your name
I'm meeting everybody on the fly oh yeah
there we go
my name is Ramon Romano's mom stand up
stand up yeah tell us tell us what your
thoughts are and then tell us what
you're going to play for us okay hold on
my name is Ramon was one Kurdish from
Syria I've been here in the US for three
three years and a half I applied for
asylum in the US and still waiting for
the decision but I I could have the
opportunity to work here and I have my
life so I think compared to my people
all over the world I am very lucky so
because I know many of my friends even
my family they scattered all over the
world and they are suffering a lot even
in the neighboring countries so some may
be may think that maybe they will be
more comfortable in the neighboring
country because they know this the
language or from very close cultural
aspects but you know at all even a few
members of my family they live in in
Iraqi Kurdistan now because I'm tradish
but at the same time even though the
even Iraqi Kurdistan they have a lot of
problems right now so we used to have a
lot of refugees in Syria me myself I was
training English back home in in
Damascus for Iraqi refugees and some
Palestinian refugees I worked with the
European Institute they're called IEC D
and we had Palestinian Iraqi Somalian
but I never thought that we Syria will
be refugees in other countries so I know
it's very hard because I would I could
have the contact or like a relationship
with other refugees from a whacky Iraqi
people and Palestinian
so I know the hardship of the being
refugee in another country but I know
because I have now
contact with my friends all over the
world Syria they have a lot of
difficulties more than the Palestinian
and Iraq II had in Syria itself so I
would thank everybody who's coming here
talk about refugees especially in the
Syrian refugees and thank you for
inviting me here I know he's doing a
great job there in Jordan with his
friends since I been is in the United
States I participated many events like
fundraising concerts for Syrians courts
even Palestinian by the way I have be a
translation from Damascus University and
they used to teach English back home but
since I got here I never thought that I
would teach English in America because
you know I I working right doors right
now
I learned how to fix garage doors here
and sometimes I think I will work in
translation but my passion is music I be
playing this instrument called SAS which
is Kurdish instrument we call it Tambor
or SAS is developed from the original
tambour which is 5000 years old so I be
playing this instrument for 30 years now
I never studied music and never studied
this instrument I just started playing
it at home when I was like 10 years old
and I think I'm professionally playing
in it so I started composing since I was
15 years old
and I've played in many venues in
Damascus and even here or in Syria in
in the United States I hope like someday
I will just do music and nothing else
you know it's very hard to make living
from music here and I think everywhere
in the world except if you are like a
big celebrity so I will participate here
now with some music maybe which is the
language of the world is a universal
language as something of my composition
and I hope you will enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the next one is gonna be my composition
is just composed it
it's a reflecting my feeling about the
whole thing that's going in my home with
all these refugees and I hope you'll
enjoy it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you